it's a complete inaccurate description
of the Middle East and Far East and the
wider region stereotyping to a point
that it gets racist oh it shows every
Muslim Arab who appears in the series as
a terrorist basically
we were like supposed to make an
authentic refugee camp and they just
wanted to have Arabic defeated there and
they didn't care about the message
there's anything really authentic in in
what is written there they just wanted
to have basically air about it we can
insert our own messages into it in a
case like homeland when it's really
degrading people and cultures that we
should try and look behind like
entertainment and also see political
messages that are transported